[Musik]
hallo herzlich willkommen sallys welt
wir haben hier gerade spargelzeit ich
liebe auch spargel am liebsten
eigentlich pur mit bissle butter und
soße in einem pfannkuchen gerollt
rezepte gibt es dafür aber schon richtig
viel auf meinem kanal heute machen wir
eine spargel tat oder einen starken cash
und dafür braucht ihr wirklich nur einen
ganz einfachen mürbeteig ihr könnt es
auch mit einem quark öl teig machen oder
ein joghurt öl teig ihr könnt auch einen
rösti boden machen so wie ich mal in der
antriebs gemacht habe heute war ganz
klassisch mit mürbeteig für den
mürbeteig verwende ich 300 gramm mehl
150 gramm kalte butter etwas salz unten
ein
den hefeteig könnte jetzt entweder mit
in händen verkneten mit einem messer
hacken oder ganz einfach in der
küchenmaschine das ist eigentlich ja ist
eigentlich alles ist recht einfach um
ziemlich schnell geht's noch einfacher
da gebe ich noch das salz dazu und die
kalte butter
und bei herzhaftem mehr beträgt nämlich
immer gerne ein ganzes sei bei dem süßen
nehme ich immer gerne nur ein eigelb
weil dann einfach dateien schmeckt aber
hier möchte ich einfach das schöne fest
wird oder eher gut aus rollen kann jetzt
einfach gut durchmischen
der sieht jetzt noch bröselig aus aber
man merkt dann gleich dass er gut
zusammen findet da braucht immer so ein
bisschen die hand wärme und wenn ihr
jetzt merkt dass er doch zu trocken ist
einfach ein schluck kaltes wasser
dazugeben nur so ein teelöffel oder
esslöffel voll kommt einfach darauf an
wie groß das ei war
jetzt einfach einen teller nehmen und
leicht flach drücken
die meisten sagen immer in
frischhaltefolie gewickelt kühl stellen
ich finde so kann man sich die frau
schaltete einfach sparen kann man
weniger müll produzieren
kurz abdecken und für eine halbe stunde
in den kühlschrank stellen
den teig nach der schulzeit kurz
durchkneten und jetzt mit ganz wenig
mädel ausrollen
ich nehme es gleich zum backen meine tat
form und zwar die mit hebe boden
so bekommt ihr nämlich tat und quiche
und die heißt dennoch bekommt ihr immer
ganz gut raus ohne dass eben etwas
kaputt geht weil man einfach die tat
oder die ki von unten hoch drücken kann
es bleibt nichts kleben und durch die
löcher bugs einfach richtig gleichmäßig
jetzt einfach ausrollen immer ein
bisschen größer als die form selbst
damit ich den rand hochziehen kann
[Musik]
ich habe immer gerne mit einer palette
hier drunter mit bisschen mehl am rand
so zieht man das mehl praktisch unter
den teig wenn er jetzt reist gar nicht
schlimm
das kriegen wir gleich wieder
zusammengeflickt das kann mal passieren
ich hätte die bevor wir jetzt auch gar
nicht denn ich habe einen mürbeteig da
ist schon fertig und patrick daher
brauche ich jetzt keinen fit ist
reinlegen
und am besten direkt so reinlegen dass
er mittig sitzt aber ist jetzt auch
nicht schlimm ich nehme ich bin ich
einfach hier den teig lag und setzt
ihnen hilft vorne dran
das kann man bei mir beteiligt ganz gut
machen
[Musik]
so kommt der teig geht's einfach ganz
kurz in den gefrierschrank oder
kühlschrank damit er noch mal richtig
schön kalt wird vor dem backen und ich
zeige euch in der zwischenzeit noch die
übrigen zutaten für die füllung verwende
ich 200 gramm rahmen 200 gramm milch
drei eiern zitronensaft ich benutze salz
pfeffer und chili etwas gastierten käse
und spargel
jetzt bereite ich zuerst die soße zu ich
nehme jetzt zuerst kaymer und zwar ist
kein markt rahmen und zwar rahmen seiner
reinsten form richtig schön cremig und
schmeckt auch vermittelt das mag ich
ganz gern aufs brot das kenne ich von
meiner mama aus der türkei und die haben
das früher immer selbst gemacht und
weicht aber super lecker also einfach
ganz ganz milde rahmen
dann kommt ihr team milch dazu sahne
könnt ihr natürlich auch nehmen aber ich
finde dann wird ein bisschen heftig die
eier dazu für die bindung da ein
bisschen salz und pfeffer jetzt nicht zu
viel salz nehmen den ich nehme gleich
noch den hirten käse und er ist auch
schon salzig
chilli mit rein und dem zitronensaft
[Musik]
ganz vorsichtig verrühren und ich habe
den schlag jetzt auch bereits geschält
und einfach in ein nasses handtuch
eingewickelt damit er nicht trocken wird
die holzigen enden habe ich weggebrochen
man bekommt natürlich aber auch
mittlerweile schon beim bauern spargel
geschält
die haben wir so eine spargel schälen
maschine ganz praktisch wieso es ist
jetzt erst mal fertig der käse kommt
gleich noch mit dazu
und jetzt kann ich schon mal beim wasser
kochen für den sport
ich habe ich jetzt einfach einen großen
topf mit wasser da gebe ich salz und
etwas zucker rein und kann jetzt einfach
den geschälten spargel drin blanchiert
gar nicht zu lange wirklich nur ganz
kurz das ein bisschen weich wird fit war
fünf minuten gar nicht länger dann nehme
ich ihnen heraus und dann kommt nämlich
ja nochmal auf die tat und kann damit
gebacken werden
[Musik]
während der spargel jetzt noch abkühlt
kann ich schon mal packen einfach kurs
ziemlich weit unten verpacken damit dass
schon ein bisschen knusprig wird und
farbe bekommt
die tat ist vorgebacken hier gebe ich
jetzt die creme drauf also diese füllung
gerammt ihr könnt ihr natürlich auch
gerne mit anderen gewürzen würzen also
ich hab es nur chili mit dran aber ihr
könnt da natürlich auch noch kräuter
dazugeben oregano oder zehn jahren alles
was er möchte
aber ich bin spargel hat einfach so
einen tollen eigengeschmack deswegen
lassen wir das jetzt so und ich lege
jetzt den spargel im ganzen drauf und
die brühe hebe ich übrigens noch auf die
schütte ich nicht weg darauf mache ich
nämlich nicht spargelsuppe sie können ja
auch ganz gut einfrieren also wenig
heute sofort eine spargelsuppe machen
möchtet oder im kühlschrank lagern dann
einfach eine suppe zubereitet
für den leckeren würzigen geschmack noch
den vierten käse nehmen davon brauche
ich jetzt nur die hälfte also 100 gramm
und den einfach so ein bisschen drüber
bröseln
ich bitte geht's die tat nicht komplett
denn ich möchte auch was vom spargel
sehen jetzt kommt die tat oder die
einfach noch mal in den backofen bei
niedrigere temperatur bei 170 grad ober
unterhitze und dann einfach so lange
backen bis die macht verstopft und dann
könnt ihr die tat entweder kalt oder
warm ist
[Musik]
die sportart ist jetzt gebacken und nach
dem backen habe ich sie mit petersilie
bestreut passt ganz gut dazu jetzt lese
ich sie aus der form dann ganz wichtig
nicht in der form schneiden sondern den
boden auf wegnehmen
am besten mit so einer palette es geht
ganz gut
wenn ihr so etwas dunkler haben wollt am
rand einfach bisschen länder drin lassen
aber ich finde es so vielleicht auch
schön so probiert
[Musik]
der murat steigert sich übrigens zu
probieren
er hat gesagt wenn es in der tat ist
will ich nicht probieren
aber ich gebe dem gleichen stück was der
hab ich liebe tat und dann probierte
sagte marie lecker der anstalt ist cool
hiermit den spargel stücken also ich
probiert es jetzt für euch übrigens kann
man natürlich und tat warm und kalt ist
dies laura vor allem weil der spargel
nicht zu weich ist also nicht matschig
festlegt sondern wirklich noch ein
bisschen bis hat recht gut schön wird
sich mit dem käse gehört das glaubt ihr
wird der morath auch schmecken definitiv
empfehlenswert probiert die klinische
tat den preis gerne mal aus und postet
gerne euer foto auf instagram oder
facebook ich wünsche euch viel spaß
dabei und ich freue mich wenn ihr mich
verlinkt damit ich es auch finden kann
also viel spaß beim nachbacken und bis
zum nächsten mal
vor allem kann man die packung und echt
100 bar mitnehmen
[Musik]